so here on our show we really love
trying to make good things happen
for people that we have on the show and
when the cameras stop rolling the story
isn't over i'm constantly wondering
how they've been doing after we've said
goodbye and i really
mean it when i say let's keep in touch
so
i invited a few of our inspiring guests
back today
for a little check-in uh but first why
don't we have a little refresh
on when they were on the show and what
their stories are take a look
[Music]
i love this next story about a dad
who built a no judgment food pantry on
his lawn
for anyone who needed groceries and when
donations started pouring in
he had to turn his entire garage into a
safe place
for a community in need i love a bigger
space and just help out more people our
friends at conagra brand believe that
everyone should have access to
great and healthy food this is from
conagra to you
thank you so much thank you
oh my god eleven-year-old zach hartman
has made it his mission to give back to
those in need by finding
new homes for used books and stuffed
animals
i've collected and donated over 65 000
books
you needed like an extra 1900 to reach
your goal
we want to give you that money and you
know what i'm just gonna do five
thank you say hello to alejandro
diaspronados from eton
elementary school my personal mission
always has been to
give my students access to a variety of
people programs resources and
connections
to and really enhance their learning
experience we actually reached out
to asus and they are giving us enough
asus chromebooks
for every single student and teacher at
ayton elementary
i like can't even fathom this this is
crazy
he saw a burning car on the street with
a mother
and her three children inside he risked
his own life to pull
each one of them out the mirror wanted
to give you this proclamation
and that's not all it's carmelo anthony
what
i want to let you know how inspiring and
courageous you are man you're a true
true hero so we're going to hook you up
some joint branch uh
merchant as a small thank you for the
big things that you've been doing man
we also found out that you're a fan of
the brooklyn nets so we have hooked you
all up we're getting you season passes
the players are excited to meet you
thank you so much thank you justin
hello monique you founded a non-profit
dance studio
serving underprivileged kids when i was
coming up we didn't have the extra funds
so i wanted to make sure that i can
offer that to
every youth that i came in contact with
i just want to say thank you and i'd
also like to contribute ten thousand
dollars
oh my god get out of here
drew don't make me cry on tv
don't do that
[Music]
okay return i'm like returning to the
show are
barney zach justin alejandro
and monique hi guys welcome back
barney drew
how are you how is the food pantry going
since we last spoke so i'm great
uh thank you again by the way being on
your first show that was such an
honor uh i'm still getting amazon
packages today from people who saw me on
your show
so thank you yes it's awesome thank you
so much
um i mean we're every other week still
uh we're about 150 to 175 people we were
up to 300 at one point which was
mind-blowing and so awesome i mean we're
we're trucking along and you know trying
to grow this thing and help as many
people as possible and you're a huge
part of that so thank you
oh that makes me so happy
and my beautiful friend zach and his mom
hi guys hi
how's everything going we're really busy
so
i was able to order 50 zax packs and 500
books
with the money that you've donated to us
and i've also donated 2 000 books to a
local title one school
also i've upcycled 200 stuffed animals
and i've given them to a human society a
humane society in louisiana
that got hit by one of our most recent
hurricanes
so i've been really busy thanks to zach
thank you truly um justin
[Applause]
i cannot stop thinking about your smile
how are you um school was going great
for me
uh i should be getting my high school
diploma about september is it your ged
what is the program
um i actually re-enrolled into school
um okay now i also want to check in
with our friend alejandro how are you
i am doing well uh you know things have
been really exciting since the show both
current and former students reached out
so many families
um you know really wanted me to give
their deepest thank you for this gift
uh and one more cool thing that actually
happened since the show so
uh that same week i was actually
surprised with an announcement
that i was named the 2021 dc teacher of
the year which was exciting
thank you so so much for this well
congratulations alejandro so well
deserved and i'll see you soon
see you soon drew thank you okay and
last but not least
welcome back monique i feel like i just
saw you the other day
how's everything going for you and your
students
oh my god so much has happened so let me
start by saying
um a lot of people were touched by the
the episode that we did
and we received donations we had
multiple
families reaching out to us wanting to
sign their kids up for the organization
most recently we had the daytona
international speedway contact us
and access if we could perform during
their race week
where the students will be performing in
front of over 100
000 people so much
so much has happened so many good things
i'm so
glad that we are linked in the chain of
your story
and you deserve all of this and i am
so happy i love when a little spark
ignites a fire
that's perfect but you're the one who
built the whole thing
thank you so much drew no monique thank
you you are so awesome this is the best
news in the world
thank you thank you okay barney zach
justin alejandro and monique
thank you for the check-in we'll talk to
you soon
you